l'international de pouvoir me faire
confiance j'estime qu'il est vraiment
nécessaire d'agir c'est vrai que je suis
plutôt quelqu'un du terrain j'ai jamais
fait de politique de ma vie il est temps
vraiment se retrousser les manches et de
faire face à cette insécurité explosive
est grandissante et c'est pour ça que
j'ai choisi de m'engager auprès de
jeunes et aux doutes que je trouve
extrêmement lucide et courageux vraiment
essayé de faire confiance et puis
j'espère que va tout mettre en oeuvre
pour remporter ces élections régionales
et qui vont servir de tremplin pour
l'accession au trône de marine le pen
alors merci à 15 m à gags bousdira
d'être avec nous alors tout le monde dit
que c'est assez fort en ce qu'il a fait
ce que vous êtes choqués ou non vous
avez vos petites pancartes par ce café
kamel l'homme qui a infiltré le
rassemblement national jusqu'à en
devenir la tête de liste dans le thé
dans le département du territoire de
belfort
c'est incroyable ça c'est une histoire
folle tout a donc commencé quand vous
intégrez le rassemblement national avec
comme objectif d'être présent sur la
liste et d'être élues et donc l'as adema
au départ c'était quoi le but au départ
le but était de créer le buzz
mais un petit buzz au niveau 1 au niveau
local quoi d'accord et là c'est je suis
ici parmi vous c'est que ça fonctionne
et parce que depuis 2006 avec des amis
très proches on a créé une association
qui s'appelle citoyenneté
ouais donc citoyenneté qui s'est créé
avec le chiffre 6 et un t majuscule en
référence au site et c'est au lendemain
des violences urbaines d'octobre
novembre 2005
et du coup on incitait les jeunes et les
moins jeunes à s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales pour pouvoir voter et même
les moins jeunes à aller voter
donc là aujourd'hui sont inscrits
automatiquement à tant mieux mais
c'était l'objectif depuis le départ donc
on a mis en place des débats on a invité
des candidats d'ailleurs un premier
débat je me souviens avait un
chroniqueur rose qui était présent la
salle était était remplie il y avait
pierre moscovici qui était candidat je
sais plus aux municipales le législatif
et donc du coup nous le but c'était de
pouvoir transmettre cet acte citoyen cet
acte citoyen concrètement alors vous
êtes monté jusqu'à être tête de liste du
rassemblement national
voilà donc c'est assez incroyable jean
bessière vous êtes avec nous cet ex
membre du rassemblement national pour
vous c'est voir s'il a fait mais c'est
surtout un gigantesque fake
pourquoi ça parce que moi j'ai eu tous
les échanges ces volets j'ai eu tout le
dossier donc avant de
avant de présenter monsieur comme
quelqu'un ayant voulu infiltré le héros
encore faut-il prendre connaissance de
tous les échanges qu'il a eus c'est quoi
ben je crois que cette cce ce monsieur
eto'o je dirais soit un lâche
soit un sale type soit les deux ce
combat soit ce que l'averse et la
version en réalité c'est que soit si
c'est un lâche et s'est engagée
effectivement au rassemblement national
et puis il s'est désengagé parce que il
a eu un petit peu de pression est donc
bah il est parti un peu la queue entre
les jambes soient effectivement il avait
vraiment l'intention de trahir dès le
départ et à ce moment là c'est encore
pire
donc moi j'ai eu des chances et volé je
perds ce que je pense je pense que cette
histoire a révélé deux choses c'est de
cesser purement factuel ce que je vais
dire un jeu soutien ni l'un ni l'autre
mais ça a révélé deux choses quand
monsieur agathe boudjellal s'est engagé
au rassemblement national vous voyez
qu'un peu comme moi il ya qu'il ya cinq
ans laura son mouvement national lui a
déroulé le tapis rouge
il l'a effectivement propulsé tête de
liste donc ça va être compliqué pour les
gens qui explique que le rassemblement
national est un parti raciste et un
parti xénophobe de le démontrer non mais
ça c'est la première chose on dit
souvent on dissout lentement
c'est l'arbre qui cache la norme est par
contre oui oui mais attendez qu'un plus
à l'est le cas à force d'arbres si vous
voulez la forêt va changer de couleur
vous avez vous êtes partie de la forêt
mais moi je suis pas tellement notre
raison pas pour cette raison là moi je
suis partant pour qu'ils arrivent on n'a
jamais su
bah si moi je suis parti parce que voilà
j'ai voulu faire autre chose j'ai voulu
me dégager un petit peu de la politique
opérationnelle avant les présidentielles
et faire et faire autre chose mais oui
j'ai déjà fait une présidentielle où en
2010 est donc j'ai alors fait ce que
c'est j'avais déjà l'expérience mais on
n'est pas là pour parler de moi si
j'étais de la demande est là de l'agro
l'un et la deuxième chose si vous
laissez que par contre quand monsieur et
je m'en parler si on n'aime pas parler
de moi comme j'ai parlé non mais je vais
à rimont fois mon propos une fois vous
vous êtes engagé et j'ai vu les attaques
dont vous avez fait l'objet qui sont
particulièrement violentes
lorsque tabou apps le journaliste
indigéniste entre journalistes entre
guillemets à balancer vos talons il vous
avait été traité d' arabes de service de
[ __ ] avec des menaces absolument
invraisemblable on va vous terminez
cetera lecomte dom et minarets pareil
tous ces gens qui à longueur de journée
nous explique que la france est un pays
aux dieux que la france est un pays
raciste vous en ai pris plein la tronche
par ces mêmes c'est vrai donc on voit
avec cette histoire où est le racisme
mais moi et je termine là
si vous le voyez ce que je regrette dans
votre nombre de dans votre démarche
c'est que en réalité le camp national
c'est à dire tous les nationaux les
patriotes qui courait représente quand
même entre 30 et 40% en france du corps
électoral
vous avez donné une très mauvaise image
parce que effectivement le risque c'est
de dire regardez quand on fait confiance
à des gens il est des français issus de
l'immigration voilà ce qu'ils nous font
est donc en fait ça s'est laissé leurs
ébats en effet pas grave c'est bojan
dans la langue à bercy donc jean messier
a - tout d'abord je vous respecte je
vous respecte je vous appelle jean
missia par jean messia si vous voulez
mais appeler les gens me scie ou de gens
le mi6 même nom mais nous voici mutation
de demain je vous parlais preuve
d'ingéniosité dans ses rues pour être
très franc et très sincère avec vous
tout d'abord jean bessière manger
beaucoup d'empathie pour vous lorsque
quand je vois ce que j'ai vécu moi ce
week end en termes d insultes de
violence de haine et de serre et
séraphine +4 c'est parti très très très
loin
commentant les vit depuis quatre ans
alors il booste encore vous de nous donc
moi je j'ai vraiment de l'empathie pour
vous c'est à dire que quand il avait dit
je vais vous expliquer quand même ouais
quand vous achetez j'ai peut-être de
liste pour les rênes c'est un
déferlement
ah oui ah oui mais complètement vendredi
qu'en ces temps monsieur arrive c'est
officiel en fait faut absolument que je
préciser une chose c'est très très très
important c'est pas par rapport aux et
rennes tous à ce que les reds un parti
politique qui est respecté par peut-être
pas tout à chacun mais qui est respecté
dans le paysage politique français ce
qui a fait mal à tout le monde et puis
qui a créé cette haine envers moi c'est
le fait d'avoir été aux côtés de julien
odoul parfait cette vidéo aux côtés de
julien odoul et puis d'être voilà avec
julien on doute parce que moi j'avais
peut-être pas anticipé ça c'est là que
j'ai perdu le contrôle c'est qu'au début
quand tu quand on s'est rapprochés avec
leur asthme en national je devais était
de luz tête de liste pardon dans le
doubs donc d'où il est originaire mais
je vais marcher r je leur ai dit écoutez
moi ma famille et c'est monsieur ne
soutiennent pas du tout c'est pas un bon
plan finalement je recrute j'ai tous les
échanges également j'ai tous les
échanges sait comment ils jouent un rôle
donc fallait que je leur dise que je
parle d'insécurité pour pouvoir avancer
tout simplement mais je vais vous
expliquer ça plus tard en tout cas tête
de liste dans le doubs ça me plaisait
pas julien odoul me rappelle le soir
même alors que j'avais j'avais refusé de
poursuivre il me dit écoute j'ai un plan
tu voyais tête de liste dans le
territoire de belfort
jeudi mais j'habite pas comment
peut-être une résidence pierre louis
labatut non t'inquiète pas c'est les
régionales tête de liste dans le
territoire de belfort ça va le faire
donc moi depuis le début il faut savoir
thé de julien aux touches de rencontres
en rencontres et en tout et pour tout je
crois trois fois donc en l'espace de
maximum 15 minutes j'étais tête de liste
au département de pro b élections
régionales je crois voix en 502 et
rennes nous a été coiffé de 10 pour les
départementales
non je ne suis pas du tout j'étais au
lycée mais si c'est déjà n'ont jamais
tant que j'ai jamais fait la critique de
ma vie candidats et moi finir si vous
l'avez pas le buzzer de booba parce que
je peux parler vous me posez la question
aux objectifs non mais faut que
j'explique à elle donc moi ma stratégie
ma stratégie d'ailleurs été de faire le
buzz a fonctionné ensuite quand j'ai vu
que j'avais l'opportunité sans faire des
campagnes contexte du couvent u19 sans
avoir été que le race mona siens de
toute ma vie je pouvais être conseiller
régional et puis vraiment m'investir
mois jusqu'en clinique j'ai regardé les
au niveau des sondages les réunionnais
des très très bon score ça m'intéressait
d'autant plus que julien odoul mois
depuis le départ je sais très bien
pourquoi il s'approche de moi c'est la
même raison pour laquelle vous êtes
succès étriqué de cette partie du réseau
national pourquoi il s'apprécie par
rapport à la dédiabolisation
cette campagne de communication bien sûr
on sait très bien la vérité ou pas c'est
incompréhensible je vous dis la vérité
c'était le 6 à artix passez moi je moi
je savais très bien sauf que ce qui a
fait tout exploser au niveau 2 au niveau
des réseaux sociaux des médias etc
c'est que généraux d'où l'émoi sage
n'est pas anticipé c'est ce qui s'était
passé avec la dame voilée dans un
hémicycle voyez y avait un petit enfant
qui pleure ça ça fait des dégâts et ça
que c'est vrai que ça moi ça paramètres
que j'ai pas pris en compte voilà et là
j'ai perdu le contrôle effectivement je
pensais pas que ça allait fermer
je pensais qu'ils allaient rester
victimes ont adopté dans cette stratégie
là c'était même si j'étais pas élu
j'avais très bien qu'au niveau le colza
et du roi kamel j'avais anticipé tout ça
moi je suis un boxeur la pression de 5
vous inquiéter même pas j'ai fait des
combats et m'aider mais ma dans des
cages moi vous inquiétez même pas la
pression moi ça me fait pas mais la
pression physique mise par là c'est sûr
nous a l'impression de comprendre les
encaisse par contre quand c'est venu sur
ma famille j'ai changé que ma famille ma
famille et moi ça passe avant tout sa
part abandonné des postes de conseiller
régional donc vous êtes en train de
reconnaître que je fais
je vais tellement simple on est bien
dans la sécurité pour avancer et pour
être ému que jamais je verrai mes yeux
mais bon les téléspectateurs en fait
kamel vous ce que vous dites c'est que
vous avez voulu intégrer le
rassemblement national pour essayer
peut-être deux voilà de démontrer que
vous étiez un petit peu le la libye du
rassemblement national et ensuite vous
vous avez commencé donc à y est les gens
ont cru parce que vous avez dis bien
tout le monde a cru que c'était vrai
vous avez pris tellement de pression que
vous avez fait machine arrière sur votre
piège que vous vouliez faire au
rassemblement national c'est ça fait
déborder pu dire c'est moi j'avais pris
jamais anticipé ça et ensuite j'étais
prêt encore encaissé sept présidents
ensuite vous et ensuite vous avez
inventé une histoire d'infiltration pour
couvrir en fait je vais maintenant que
je fais pas tous cas ce que je vous
dirais je vous aime et qui jamais mais
une question d'importance il vous dit
c'est le tout tout ce trafic
il s'est depuis dit que si je voulais
faire et pendant que je me suis rendu
compte à l'intérieur et ses petits mois
parce que là j'ai des choses à raconter
par contre pris alors il ya un monsieur
qui s'appelle jacques qui a été très
bienveillants envers moi un rêve
traduire et n'est pas associé k way il
était très bien très correct dès la
première rencontre sur un parking d'un
grand magasin parce que peut pas encore
se rencontrer dans le quartier etc
il me dit tu sais t'inquiète page
d'origine italienne pourtant le camp
mécanicien il essaie un arabe
donc tant que c'était des quartiers je
crois que c'était des quartiers
humaniste tolérant son action de suite
ça tournait autour de ça bon y'a pas de
soucis on va poursuivre ensuite l'ordre
de 2 3 points de rencontre on empêchait
moi on m'a empêché d'être en contact
visuel avec votre candidat parce que je
savais que ça gênait un moment donné pas
mais je m'avoue mentir quand même
pendant six mois j'ai pas filmer mais un
moment donné quand je vais chez un
monsieur hees est un ami d'être là parce
que beaucoup junia roudoule puisse me
dire écoutez que témoin s'il vous plaît
à montrer nos l'épreuve jurait roudoule
puisse me dire je vais être tête de
liste j'ai des gens qui doivent pas me
voir je vous dis je rentre ça dure trois
minutes d'habitude tout ce qui est
politique c'est celle en lien avec le
vivre ensemble mon véhicule mais malheur
etc je suis rentré chez moi qui gère le
débat je suis rentré bâtiment 15
secondes je me suis ainsi une minute
trente au chrono on me dit tu voyais
tête de liste et on m'a raccompagné très
vite vers la sortie j'ai pas compris
dans les justes notamment parce que
derrière vendant chèque d autres
candidats on allait faire leur fête sans
moi kamel qu'avec est où
je vous le dis que c'est dû mais aucune
tromperie la conférence avait aucune
logique narrative conférence de presse
vendredi à belfort ce qui se massent à
montner ils sont lâchés ne dure pas moi
je fais le ramadan donc je me suis
éclipsé chauffe venu et puis je sais pas
s'il s'était rendu compte que j'étais
revenu ou pas mais c'est en plus un
deuxième ou troisième tête de liste 1 /
yeux sur un haut niveau des cantonales
je crois cela commence à dire oui vous
savez hier moi dans mon bar avec deux
meilleurs y avait deux maghrébins
oui j'ai plein d'exemples comme ça où ça
fait rachète de magret mais là en étant
je vous jure
oula moi j'ai cru maghrébins que marine
le pen avait fait un beau boulot un bon
boulot parce que depuis des années vous
devrez à dédiaboliser le parti et moi de
m'en donner les gens quand ils me
disaient elles feront un seul attendez
c'est pas le premier salle c'est le
rassemblement national et donc les
partis politiques
excusez moi donc tu n'es pas de télé
vous verrez quand chaque fois des micros
des chroniqueurs des journalistes ou des
politiciens ils disent front national a
jamais jamais ils sont originaux
répondre non mais je te demande et parce
que jamais ils sont corrigés voyez
jamais à son corrigez moi je vous dirais
ne s'écrira pas levé dédiabolisation là
moi je me suis rendu compte justement à
l'intérieur et ce à partir de ce moment
là moi non mais c'est un dj infiltré de
l'intérieur et sécurité
quand même c'était la même gamelle avec
moi trop discuter là on arrête de
discuter que domitia je peux répondre
d'abord deux minutes n'étaient pas deux
minutes
remettons costumes et je m'en occupe
jusqu'à belle ce que vous êtes en train
de dire juste et que vous avez remarqué
pour vous que le rassemblement national
quand vous dites ils se sont vite lâché
si vous avez vu des propos qu à des
propos racistes mac os voilà c'est ça ça
ça arrive ça faisait allusions racistes
c'est ça quand tu chasses naturel il
revient au galop d'accord donc si vous
voulez moi je pense que vos propos sont
diffamatoires parce que vous avez aucune
preuve de ce que vous avancez vous avez
des micros vous avez avec l'arabe parlé
km vous avez un narratif a posteriori
qui celui qu'il aime et on imagine mal
le contraire c'est là vous pouvez pas
faire ce que vous avez fait en sorte en
disant finalement c'était vachement bien
donc vous êtes obligé de vous êtes
obligé de finir vous aimez vous êtes
obligés d'inventer a posteriori une
histoire pour couvrir entre l'ensemble
de la logistique en fait je vais vous
dire un truc vous avez un filtre est
imparti d'accord je veux bien l'admettre
ça mais quand on infiltre en partie on y
reste quand même coup plusieurs mois on
attend d'être élu pour avoir une vision
globale
là vous êtes infiltrez vous est barrée
ou trois jours mais aussi très quoi mais
ma mémoire est mûr qui est infiltrée au
bout de trois jours d'affilée mais je
remets cerveau j'ai pas honte de dire
que la pression effectivement le faire
reculer bien sûr voilà donc c'est
uniquement sur arm est inventée par les
histoires parce que c'est malhonnête
dans tous les habitants 10 ans et en
blesser au comblement salah kamel
sanhadji alors non j'ai une telle
émergence promis 15 secondes
km je me fais appeler km avec mondial
alors sur makarine entier c'est kamel
boudjellaba penh cambodia là parce que
quand je vais dans un moteur de
recherche très connu et je tapais kamel
morjane a envoyé tout ce que j'ai fait
en termes de militants les associations
les débats que j'ai mené que des
politiciens tout ce que j'ai pu mener
heureusement la star n'aurait pas
accepté en fait qu'ils aient déjà
bédéphiles traitement si vous êtes quoi
ou six mois tu as lease et s'il vous
plaît vous êtes j'en amis facebook j'ai
dû le supprimer parce qu'on voit
manifester et sera donc pas partir
d'objets mais comme elle à agathe buja
là quand on tapait dans le moteur de
recherche y avait plus rien et on tombe
sur des archives des articles qui joue
en faveur du ralliement national de
losne c'est vous dire c'est à dire la
réalité vous avait attisé la haine aussi
bien de la part à ce n'est pas le but de
tous et compte de la diversité du condom
et minarets et caetera et vous avez été
les victimes vous et votre famille et
vous avez attiser la haine également des
nationaux et des patries montrer la
réalité en france les banques que vous
avez 6
10% même nom à 44 s'envoyer 56 % des
gens qui ont été choquées par voilà les
votre intégration et rennes pour les
piéger
voilà kamel donc vous avez entendu la
version de kamel dont je peux prendre
vos réactions juge gilles verdez bah moi
je suis choquée parce que je trouve
qu'il ya eu un manque de sincérité au
départ et votre reculade honnêtement je
la comprends pas mais dites vous êtes
imperméable à la pression
vous vous retirez j'ai pas compris je
n'y crois pas même si jamais été des
partis politiques gens vendent beaucoup
de partis politiques j'ai côtoyé les
politiques il est temps que je veux la
vérité comme aux gens ce qui fait ce qui
fait que la france est dans cet état
aujourd'hui c'est certain dégoût mais
c'est que notre quartier mais ça c'est
clair et net
par contre il faut arrêter que les
politiques qui dirigent tout face du
théâtre ce que moi j'ai prouvé que c'est
très simple en fait c'est du théâtre tu
encore tu joues tu sors c'est ce que
vous avez séjour il faut plus théâtre
les jeux les jeux sans minorer six zones